[Music]
edie
how are you feeling right now
what are you feeling
[Music]
that it's really difficult to be around
people
because they just want me to be better
so you're not able to
share what you're feeling with other
people
it's pretty country tribal lands
it's not a good idea to be out here
without a vehicle
i'll be fine
you said your family was from the city
uh
how did you find me you ordered my path
you know one might wonder how someone
like you
came to be in this place i'm not
running from anyone i'm not hiding
i'm here because i choose to be
if it's all right i will teach you how
to trap
and fall to hunt and then you won't see
me anymore
can we agree that you not bring any news
of life elsewhere
what if aliens land here
do you have family my wife and my
daughter were
killed in a car accident
[Music]
you ever get lonely out here i know i'd
be more lonely there than here
my niece proved this for my herbert
friend
who lives in the mountains
and tell me about your family
[Music]
have you thought about what you want
your life to be now
[Music]
[Music]
you